dairo antonio ushiga is widely known as
otonia and had been on the run for more
than a decade
colombia's most wanted and most feared
drug trafficker now finally in handcuffs
after being hunted down by soldiers
[Applause]
for the world's largest cocaine
producing nation authonial's arrest is
the biggest victory in its so-called war
on drugs in nearly 30 years
this is the hardest blow that has been
dealt to drug trafficking in this
century in our country
and this blows only comparable to the
fall of pablo escobar in the 90s
he was captured at his hideout in jungle
near the border with panama
more than 500 soldiers were deployed one
officer was killed
we began an important satellite
surveillance mission against him with
agencies from the u.s and uk
where with each movement with trace
analysts with communications more than
50 experts in signal intelligence
permanently covering that area with an
exact coverage that allowed us to
indicate what his movements were to get
him from his hiding place
born into a rural family otoniel was a
hardened fighter who switched sides from
far-left guerilla to far-right
paramilitary groups in 2012 he took over
as the leader of the gulf clan from his
brother who was killed by police
he's wanted by the u.s reporting tons of
cocaine for years from south america
the government says his group has been
behind some of the worst violence
colombia has seen since the signing of a
peace deal with farc rebels in 2016.
there is the possibility that these
bring down levels of violence especially
on the communities that have been
affected by this large organization but
but indeed i mean there is no
an effective
solution to the
drug trafficking international drug
trafficking problem just by beheading
these type of organizations that won't
solve the narcotics problems in the
world not nor in colombia
many fear authorial's arrest may lead to
a power struggle and a tough war that
could worsen the violence priyanka gupta
al-jazeera